Wagner's forces occupied Russia's
military headquarters in roster Von Dawn
early on Saturday the group claimed to
have shot down a Russian military
helicopter and in turn a Wagner military
Convoy came under Fire on a highway
outside the city of varunesh pictures
also emerged of almost 200 Russian
troops surrendering to Wagner
the video of The Mercenaries on the
streets of the city in southern Russia
immediately flooded social media some
mercenaries even finding the time to
order fast food
it wasn't long before Russia's president
was addressing the nation and vowing
retribution
we will protect our people and our
statehood from any threats including
internal betrayal and what we are facing
is betrayal exorbitant Ambitions and
personal interests led to treason
the Russian leader spelling out just how
serious he thinks the threat from Wagner
is
any internal turmoil is a deadly threat
to our statehood to us as a nation this
is a blow to Russia to our people
Russia's defense Ministry appealed to
Wagner fighters to abandon progression
saying they'd been tricked into what was
described as their leaders criminal
adventure and participation in an armed
Rebellion
tension between Wagner and the kremlin's
Armed Forces escalated during the Battle
of bakmut where the mercenaries played a
crucial role in the drawn out fighter
capture the city
pregosian accused the Russian army
commanders of deliberately withholding
ammunition and other supplies from his
men
in an audio recording precaution denied
Putin's accusation of treason
we are patriots of our homeland we had
been fighting and we are fighting now no
one is going to turn themselves in on
demand of the president FSB or anyone
else because we do not want any more of
our country to live in corruption lies
and bureaucracy this is why we are the
Patriots and those who are against us
are the ones surrounding the scumbags
police raided Wagner's headquarters in
Saint Petersburg while in Moscow
security has been tightened and what's
described as a counter-terrorism state
of emergency imposed Michael Apple Al
Jazeera